how many people listening to us today do
you think know their VO2 max very few
there is no metric that I am aware of
that is more highly correlated with the
length of a person's life than their VO2
max why that particular metric there's
probably two things going on right one
it actually does matter a lot it's an
amazing proxy for health have you heard
of yot Max test done recently last one
was probably four years ago it is
testing your maximal consumption of
oxygen well to get to that level we are
stressing you to the highest degree
possible the higher that number is the
more oxygen your muscles can utilize the
more fit you are the more capacity you
have to avoid illness I think the other
reason for it is that it's a metric that
is so ubiquitous it's very standardized
to have a high number you must be
exercising a lot and we know the
benefits of exercising a lot the person
who has a VO2 max at the top two percent
of their age by definition they're doing
a lot of exercise and exercise has more
benefit than probably any other single
intervention we can do